in other news high winds in california's
wine country are whipping up that
already devastating wildfire out there
multiple wildfires in california the
glass fire has burned more than 58
thousand acres since it started sunday
more than 600 buildings have been
destroyed including 220
homes john the bigliotti followed
firefighters in napa valley where he got
a dramatic look
at what they're up against jonathan good
morning to you
good morning to you we've been watching
all week long as firefighters have been
battling planes like this you're looking
at a home completely
engulfed this neighborhood first went
back on sunday the flames were
extinguished
but then overnight winds picked up those
hot spots
creating a new inferno
[Music]
it's a race against time and the
elements
the increasingly hot windy weather is
giving the glass fire
everything it needs to grow on thursday
it near the town of anguin
threatening more homes and businesses
more than 2 thousand firefighters are on
the front lines
we embedded with a team working at the
fire's southern edge
this wind event has caused this fire to
explode strike teams are here on site
trying to put these flames out before
the wind picks up even more if we
have some limited aircraft that we have
that we're using
the problem is has been the air
conditions they can't fly in the
smoke conditions that we've been
experiencing but when the smoke clears
the aircraft mobilized quickly and this
is what backup looks like this
helicopter now able to grab water
to drop on those flames newly released
video shows the magnitude of the battle
this is what firefighters are seeing
driving through a flame-filled landscape
where homes are
already fully engulfed by fire creating
red hot pools along the roadside
meanwhile the four victims of the zog
fire near the oregon border have been
identified
including a mother and her
eight-year-old daughter
according to a gofundme page elena and
phala mcload
tried to flee their home but their car
was seen stuck in a ditch
with no one inside
we are told nobody was inside this home
at the time when this fire broke out
overnight
the high winds that are fueling these
flames are expected to continue
through today pushing this fire deeper
into napa valley tony jonathan thank you
very much for thinking this morning
about that mother and her little girl
that's hard it's tough stuff all right
very difficult